as someone that has to work out as for a
job i i promise you i would not look
like this unless
i had to be naked in most of my movies
mostly and
and like at some point i got to get
better at acting so i don't have to be
naked in all of them
but she is just incredible i i really
i mean i literally get to work out as a
job
and it is it and it's still hard and i
can't imagine people
that have have a nine-to-five job have
kids at home
and then where do they get the energy
and the time to to actually like
you know focus on themselves and i just
think it's really beautiful what she's
doing
absolutely and you get it your dad
that's like there's a lot of time like
just for work and then you're a dad
it's like it's a lot like to fit
everything in um so do you
do you do like massive cheat days
because dwayne
um johnson was on here and he showed me
his cheat day and i was like
first of all i would barf if i ate all
the things he ate on his sheet today
but do you have massive ones i sometimes
do
uh not like not like massive ones
because i think as i'm getting older
it's really getting like everything i
pick up i just go oh that's like
two more miles that i have to run a ride
and and it's like
i just start looking at things like
they're just actual miles and time that
i have to work out so
yeah i will pick the days and i will
pick very specific things i love cake
but uh but yeah it's yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever